questions concerns continue when it
comes to fraud related unemployment
issues many
still having problems with their bank of
america issued accounts
joel mohler live at dieter this evening
with more on what people are worried
about now joe it seems like an endless
litany
of issues
yeah it feels like there's always
something well now people are having
issues trying to get their accounts
reopened it's a continuing issue people
have been waiting for
quite a while and some of those people
who actually got their accounts reopened
are now having a problem trying to get
that money
that was allegedly taken from their
accounts back in it
so i just received a letter in the mail
from them
leandria vaughn first noticed money
taken from her account in november
she got her account reopened recently
but never received the four hundred
dollars she says was stolen
it says they uh completed a review of
the above reference
claim and have determined that no error
has occurred in this instance
we now consider your claim resolved
yvonne says the money was taken from an
atm she was never at
but i've never spoke with anyone from
bank of america any investigative unit
we reached out to bank of america to see
if people can dispute the decisions
they tell us you can call the number on
the back of your card to get the fraud
claim
looked at again and to get more
information for as of right now i have
no problems with bank of america
it's on the deter side now after filing
a fraud complaint through the consumer
financial protection bureau richard
swayze actually got his stolen money
back and his account reopened
but never received his unemployment
benefits he missed during that time
he now has another issue i have this bpc
id notification on my
website saying that it's been suspended
pinning resolution
he's already missed two more payments
and now is left scratching his head
i don't know if dieter has to verify if
they're verifying bank of america send
all the funds back
what the deal is
and about here live swayze also says
he's on a number of different facebook
groups and is noticing others with the
same sort of issues so we did reach out
to dieter today to see if we can get any
sort of answer about
that specific window but we have yet to
hear back as soon as we do hear back
from them we'll be sure to update this
story
reporting live here at dieter joe mohler
8 news now